clouds swirl around Mount samiru as
Columns of Ash blast into the air
the plume reaching a height of 15
kilometers was accompanied by searing
gas people living in nearby Villages
fled in panic
[Music]
traffic log jammed amid poor visibility
many are unsure of where to spend the
night
but I'm a block it's raining in my
village now and you can't see anything
it's raining volcanic ash I don't know
where to go the most important thing is
to run away from the village to save my
family
authorities have warned people not to
come within eight kilometers of the
crater
we have readied some nearby schools and
Village Halls they will be made
available until the observatory declares
it is safe
samaru known as the great mountain is
the highest volcano in Java and one of
the most active
when it erupted last December entire
Villages were buried in mud and at least
50 people were killed
Indonesia has 142 volcanoes and is home
to the largest population living within
close range of a crater
this eruption won't be the last
it's not a question of if
but when
Andrea van wyk Al Jazeera